ils se sont levés aux aurores leur
journée aura débuté très tôt aujourd'hui
il est à peine 8 heures voilà on va
avoir les différents animaux qu'on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir comme agent
l'éthique on peut pas avoir tous les
jours donc ça va faire du bien mais
après deux heures de route depuis dijon
ils sont enfin arrivés tout comme
d'autres familles certains n'ont pas de
voiture ils profitent de cette journée
pour pouvoir venir ici c'est donc parti
pour une journée de découverte zèbres
tigres blancs lyon au chameau séduisent
petits et grands
[Musique]
et
ici ils peuvent voir 140 espèces et plus
de 700 animaux alors ils foulent la
dizaine d'hectares du parc et apprennent
beaucoup de choses
je n'ai pas eu
kaeppelin animaux qu'on des noms qu'on
connaît pas du tout donc franchement
c'est impressionnant et c'est
franchement génial cette journée est
organisée par le secours populaire
aujourd'hui la place est faite aux
familles qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer des vacances il ya des familles
monoparentales des femmes sol il ya des
retraités y a des on a beaucoup de mamie
aussi qui viennent avec les petits
enfants à ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas à eux
offrir non plus des entrées c'est pas
donné un parc
après une courte pause changements de
température ils sont nombreux à se
diriger vers l'espace aquatique ou
phoques et girafes sont remplacés par
des toboggans
je suis vraiment content de partir et de
faire le toboggan ça change de la maison
et une journée bien chargée pour toutes
ces familles les enfants pourront donc
raconter leur sortie à la rentrée